[Music]
covid19 has proved to be one of the most
virulent
and disruptive viruses to have ever
swept the world
but the death toll is much worse than
what is widely reported
official statistics suggest that the
virus has claimed around
3 million lives but a statistical model
created by the economist
calculates the number to be more than
triple that
it's likely that between 7 and thirteen
million people
have died as a result of the pandemic so
why are our calculations
so much higher than official statistics
our data journalist andre ulvin solstad
explained how it was done for the
economist's podcast
the jab
sandra you've been researching the
number of excess deaths
since the pandemic began how accurate
is the official death toll not very
to be honest um it depends a lot on
which country you are in
uh for instance in america it's pretty
accurate we think access deaths are
about seven percent higher
but in many developing countries the
mismatch is enormous
so according to our modeling the total
account of excess death
is about maybe three or four times um
the official death toll that's
quite an undercount i just wonder if you
could step us through
how you've calculated the uh your
estimate for the real
death toll of the pandemic so i think
the first thing is to
to know what excess deaths are so these
are the deaths we observe compared to
those we would expect in normal years
now many countries account excess debts
or count total debts and enabling us to
calculate excess debts
but most don't and so the challenge
becomes estimating access that's where
they are unknown
you don't want to just sort of spit out
a number and say
here's the truth because
the truth is you can't actually know the
exact number of excess
that's the data just doesn't exist so
what we've done
and invested a tremendous effort in
doing is to provide ranges that capture
the the variation that we think is
possible
but on those ones where there isn't good
data i just wonder could you explain how
you filled in those gaps well for one
thing we used a
whole lot of data so we tried to collect
as much data as we could on all sorts of
indicators
so that if some data was missing at
least we would have some other data that
perhaps could fill in
altogether we had 121 indicators in our
models
on everything from demography to
geography to
how much people moved around and so on
we then did a few other things
the first thing we did is that when data
was missing we recorded it
because there is information provided in
a data point being missing it says
something
in itself the second thing we did was
that we constructed indicators based on
what was happening in nearby countries
so if you don't know how much testing is
going on in
one country how much testing is going on
in the countries around it might be
indicative
or at least give you some information
another thing we did was that we we
tried to do region averages
so maybe countries in africa or
countries in latin america tend to be
similar in some ways
enabling us to fill in the gaps where
data was missing okay so based on your
modeling
the pandemics claimed around 10 million
lives
which parts of the world have been more
or less effective than perhaps
we've realized as one might expect the
undercount is most severe in poor and
middle-income countries
in these places testing is less
widespread
mostly because it is expensive and
that's something that
officials there like to prioritize we
also suspect that in some countries
governments might not prioritize testing
because it would reveal how bad the
pandemic really is
for instance in russia the excess deaths
are about
five times the official count moving it
from
a somewhat light-hit country uh to one
of the most severely hit in europe and
the world
anyone watching can find out what our
statistical model says about their part
of the world
by clicking on the link above it goes to
an interactive map
so andre are there parts of the world
where excess deaths are actually lower
than they would have been
yes there are actually indeed places
like that
um where they have deficit deaths so the
most
most sort of straightforward are are
australia and new zealand
where the lack of a flu season and
the lack of many deaths to covet mean
that that's overall
are down from last year there are also
some countries in europe
for instance norway where deaths are
lower than one would expect
probably again because of less
transmission of infectious diseases
and so give us some more examples of the
kinds of countries that
have been more overwhelmingly hit i mean
the shape of the pandemic
that is in the popular narrative is that
there have been a couple of waves around
the world
and that for example now india is going
through
a very severe time in its second wave is
that really what happened
according to your modelling you don't
think so um
unfortunately there was no first and
second wave but there's just been
one enormous wave and then a further
spike now that
india descends into a tragedy
what we found was that their
pandemic hit of course china first but
but then the rich world where that's
where
somewhat accurately reported after that
it moved into the more isolated and less
internationally connected developing
countries
causing mass amounts of deaths there
um in indeed deaths have been rising for
most of the past year and every month
that is not total debts but that's per
day
what we're seeing now is another spike
driven by what is happening in india
where we think about
20 000 people die every day compared to
about 4 000
which is the official tally what did
your modelling tell you about
the the about india itself
is is india an outlier or is it
something that we can expect to see
more of in terms of the the rates of
death and the rates of infection
unfortunately india is is not an outlier
actually
many countries are modeling suggests
have been much harder hit than india
for instance peru which is one of the
worst hit in the world
i've seen deaths per person or per
million population
about 2.5 times what we currently
estimate is the case in india
what we instead think is happening is
that
india is it's just something
that we probably should expect has the
experience of this pandemic been
different
in the rich world versus the poor world
in terms of
how the populations are structured in
those countries and therefore
how many deaths have occurred the
overall story of the pandemic
as revealed by these models fits well
with what we now know about the disease
how easily it spreads and who it kills
that's have been relatively high
in rich countries including europe and
america and canada and so on
but the reason for this we believe
is that the disease is just extremely
dependent on age old people die
at much much higher rates than young
people
one of the things for instance that we
did was that we calculated the expected
infection fatality rate
on a country-by-country basis based on
their population
so this would be taking a random person
off of that country
or from that country looking at their
age and
gender and then looking at what tends to
happen of people
with similar age and gender in the rich
country
if you start adjusting for demography in
this way you find that
the disease would be about 10 times more
deadly in italy than in uganda
because uganda's population is just that
much younger
so what is probably happening is is that
these countries have somewhat comparable
death rates
simply because they're so young likely
infections are
much more widespread there and that's
the reason why
the numbers become comparable because if
they were not
a lot fewer people would die i'm sandra
alvan solstad a data journalist at the
economist
you can read more about our model and
what we find by clicking the link
thanks for watching
you